- This video is brought to you by Keeps.
(upbeat music)
What's up everybody,
Michael here to talk about
the world's leading advocate
against amphibians sexual agency.
- I don't like 'em putting
chemicals in the water
that turn the frigging frogs gay.
- Alexander Emerick Jones.
There have been better times
to be Mr. Jones's wallet.
Actually has there ever been a good time
to be inside the pants
of Alex Jones regularly?
I don't think so.
Last month he was ordered
to pay over $49 million
in a defamation lawsuit
brought by the parents of the children
killed in the Sandy Hook massacre.
Indeed, thanks largely to Jones' influence
a staggering one in five Americans
thinks Sandy Hook was staged.
But even if you aren't among
the nearly 20% of Americans
convinced that grieving parents
are actually well paid actors,
the chances are you've stumbled upon
your fair share of
misinformation on the internet.
This leaves us wondering,
why is contemporary discourse
so filled with misinformation?
What's more, are these falsehoods
threatening the very
fabric of our society?
And do shared societal
truths even exist anymore?
Let's investigate in
this "Wisecrack" edition,
is misinformation here to stay?
So what is misinformation anyway?
Well as defined by the CUNY
Graduate School of Journalism,
it's the sharing of inaccurate
and misleading information
in an unintentional way.
It's often accompanied
by its more villainous
sibling, disinformation,
which is misinformation spread
with the intention to deceive
typically to further political goals.
Now, miss and disinformation
have been around since
the first Neanderthal
took false credit for inventor fire,
but misinformation needs
widespread mediums of communication
to really spread.
Take ancient Rome
where coins were basically
the first mass produced
methods of communication,
regularly used to project ruler's power
and convey state propaganda.
It didn't take long
for Julius Caesar's adopted son, Octavian,
to use engraved coins
to spread disinformation
about his rival, Mark Antony,
calling him among other things,
a raging alcoholic and a
trader for marrying Cleopatra.
Skip ahead to the invention
of the printing press,
which significantly lowered the barrier
to circulate your ideas.
There were political
ramifications to this,
like when rebels trying to take down
England's King George II,
filled papers with fake stories
claiming that he was ill.
King George ultimately prevailed,
but the rebels kick-started a solid game
of political health shaming
that, unlike King George,
remains alive and well today.
As for America, it's been
a wash with misinformation
since the colonial days,
when posters and pamphlets
propagated biased politicized news.
Benjamin Franklin himself
amplified revolutionary fervor
by pending propaganda stories
about Indigenous Americans
colluding with King George III.
I don't know much for sure,
but I know that if your
name is King George
people probably hate you.
When American newspapers
emerged in the early 18OOs,
they balanced hard news with
straight up fake stories,
like the "Great Moon Hoax"
in which the "New York Sun" claimed
there was an alien colony on the moon.
By the 1890s, what we now
call yellow journalism
erupted as newspaper magnates.
Joseph Pulitzer and
William Randolph Hearst
battled in a circulation war
using misleading and fantastical
headlines to sell papers.
Think of it as early click bait,
except they weren't clicking,
they were grabbing papers.
So we'll call it grab bait.
The influence of yellow journalism
is often cited as one
of the driving forces
of the Spanish-American War.
So yes, some guys that own
newspapers helped start a war.
It sounds fun.
Unsurprisingly, this is
around when the term fake news
seems to have enter the lexicon.
If it sounds like early America
was a wash in (bleep) news,
it's because it totally was.
But as philosopher, Jacob Soll, writes,
yellow journalism had a backlash effect.
As people sought out more
objective or reputable news,
newspapers started hiring
better-educated reporters and journalists
to cover fact-based news
about business in the economy
for the wealthy investor class.
Papers started relying
on the subscription model
which further disincentivized
disinformation
because customers could simply switch
to a competitor's paper
if they felt they were being duped.
So again, the free
market fixes everything.
All of this created an
entirely novel media climate.
As historian Jonathan Ladd writes,
"The existence of an
independent, powerful,
widely respected news media establishment
is an historical anomaly.
Prior to the 20th century,
such an institution had never
existed in American history."
The government also
played a big role in this.
By 1937, a Roper poll
asking, is the press fair
showed that 66% of Americans said yes.
Continuing this trend in 1949
after television entered the picture,
the Federal Communications Commission
sought to preserve objective news
with the fairness doctrine,
which required broadcast news
to present balanced coverage
and to supplement controversial
opinions with counterpoints.
When the policy was axed by
Ronald Reagan's FCC in 1987,
everything changed.
Wow, Ronald Reagan ruined
something in the 80s.
This is crazy.
According to the "Washington Post,"
almost overnight, the media
landscape was transformed.
Opinionated news,
including talk radio shows
like Rush Limbaugh's
exploded on the scene.
- This is also a benevolent dictatorship.
I am the dictator.
There is no first amendment
here, except for me.
We have one responsibility,
and that is to have the
listeners of this show enjoy it,
and be entertained, and drawn
to it, and want to stay.
- At the same time newsroom shrank,
and the 24-hour news cycle emerged.
"The need to produce
greater quantities of news
at a faster pace," according
to scholar, David A. Logan,
"incentivize journalists to
get the news first and fast
rather than first and right."
Misinformation, unsurprisingly followed.
For example, in 1985, the
Soviet Union started a rumor
that AIDS had been created
in a us military laboratory.
This spread like wildfire
and by 1987, reporter Dan Rather,
repeated the accusations on CBS
without asking the
government for a response.
By the time the internet rolled
around, all bets were off.
If the printing press lowered the barrier
to spread information,
the internet obliterated it.
But the digital web of misinformation
was far less mainstream.
As scholar, Dave Karp, writes,
"Conspiratorial websites in the mid 1990s
also had a sharply limited audience.
This was the pre-Google internet,
where search was time
consuming and difficult.
If you wanted to find information
about all manner of Clinton
conspiracies in 1997,
you would've had to look pretty hard."
That was about to change
thanks to a little thing
formerly known as TheFacebook.
- Drop the, the.
Just Facebook.
- But before we get into it,
I wanna talk to you about
this video's sponsor, Keeps.
Now, you might have heard
the alarming statistic
that two out of three men
will experience male pattern baldness
by the time they're 35.
And while that's totally wild,
you don't need to worry
because you got Keeps.
Now, Keeps is a subscription service
that makes it easier and more affordable
to prevent hair loss.
You start with a free consultation
with a licensed Keeps doctor
who will help you get
the right combination
of FDA-approved prescriptions
and over-the-counter medications.
And you'll never have to worry
about running out of your Keeps products
thanks to an automatic refill
that arrives at your door
every three months.
Now, if you have any questions
or if you wanna share progress updates,
you can message or Keeps doctor 24/7.
Results appear within four to 12 months.
So get started today
to hang on to the hair you have.
Join the hundreds of thousands
of men who've tried Keeps
and given it more five star reviews
than any of its competitors.
If you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss,
go to keeps.com/wisecrack,
or click the link in the description
to receive 50% off your first order.
That's K-E-E-P-S.com/wisecrack.
Now, back to the show.
While there's a long history
of misinformation in America,
things are definitely different today.
It's reach has been exacerbated
by changes in how the internet,
and especially social
media spread information.
Some of this has to do with
the way traditional news
pivoted online,
where the metric of
the page view was king.
In the year since,
things like social media
shares and engagement
have become another important way
of measuring digital success.
As data scientists, Noah
Giansiracusa writes,
"Contemporary pageview-driven news
is the regrettable
19th-century yellow press
on digital steroids."
With competition for attention
more intense than ever
and advertising revenue and
subscription numbers down,
even legacy media outlets
have started relying more
on heavily charged emotions
and extreme opinions.
This is exemplified by
someone like Tucker Carlson,
who fended off a slander lawsuit in 2020
when a judge ruled the viewers
should already know that
he's not stating actual facts
and is presenting non-literal commentary
- M&Ms will not be satisfied
until every last cartoon
character is deeply unappealing
and totally androgynous
until the moment you
wouldn't wanna have a drink
with any one of of them.
That's the goal.
When you're totally turned off,
we've achieved equity, they've won.
- You and me both Tucker.
The shift has also changed
the way we view the
obligations of reporters.
As scholar Norman Fairclough explains,
"In addition to the knowledgeable reporter
informing the interested citizen,
there is an element of the media artist
entertaining the viewer as consumer."
Across mediums, this has led
to the rise of infotainment,
or news presented
with all the trappings
of conventional entertainment formats,
or entertainment presented
with all the trappings
of the news format.
- I'm here at the Pentagon
to find out what Space Force,
the sixth and coolest branch
of the U.S. military does.
I'm talking spaceships, lasers.
It's the military in space.
- It's worth noting that
news hasn't always been
about the hustle to make money.
Mark Gunther notes that as
recently as the late 1970s
"There was no network news business.
The Big Three broadcast
television networks
all covered news,
but none generally made money doing so.
Nor did they expect to turn
a profit from news program."
In contrast, as scholar,
Jayson Harsin, notes,
internet news rapidly became
a money-making venture,
writing, "The digital
communication infrastructure
is not designed to suit
democratic political communication
or trust-worthy information,
but rather to suit recent
forms of consumer capitalism,
the attention economy."
As we've become habituated
to perpetually shocking headlines,
disinformation has flourished.
Karb says, "To state it plainly,
fake news in the 1990s was a hobby.
Today it is an industry."
For that matter,
it's an industry worth nearly
a quarter billion dollars
in online ad revenue annually as of 2019.
Almost 40% of that
revenue came from Google.
Algorithmically primed to boost content
that insights our most extreme emotions,
social media has been crucial
to the spread of misinformation.
We talked about this in a recent video,
but it's worth repeating.
Controversial ideas equate
to virality on social media.
As journalist, Stuart A Thompson
and Charlie Warzel write,
"Facebook's algorithms
have coaxed many people
into sharing more extreme
views on the platform,
rewarding them with likes and shares
for posts on subjects like
election fraud conspiracies,
COVID=19 denialism, and
anti-vaccination rhetoric."
In recent years,
such stories of an amplified
by bot farms and meme accounts,
which efficiently churn out misinformation
in the form of recognizable
visual jokes and catchy slogans.
Importantly, memes are
extremely hard to moderate,
or if you're a member of Gen X,
extremely hard to understand.
So even when social media platforms
attempt to weed out disinformation,
images of Obama as a lizard
person can skirt by undetected.
But while it's easy to
blame misinformation
on the evolved media landscape,
we think there's something more going on.
Harsin argues that we live
in a cultural ambiance
of post-truth defined by a
breakdown of social trust.
Harsin blames the mainstreaming
of this public anxiety about truth
on the influence and
persuasion industries,
like PR, marketing, and
political communications.
He writes that they went from
appealing to people's reason
to strategically managing
their emotions and attention
via organized systematic lying.
Such lying is now seen
as banal, unremarkable,
even expected in commercials
or political speech.
Harsin argues that increasingly,
journalism and opinionated commentary
use the same emotional appeals
of politicians and advertisers.
As a result, people tend
to measure believability
in what makes them feel the most,
and outrageous disinformation
can make us feel a lot.
It's fitting that Alex
Jones's reporting style
is defined by his pathos.
Frequently expressed an angry
and passionate outburst.
In the absence of evidence,
the proof lies in his emotional appeal
- Infowars.com-
- It's dawn half past 11.
You're watching the "Sunday Politics."
We have an idiot in the program today.
Coming up in just 20 minutes.
- You will not stop freedom!
You will not stop the republic!
Humanity is awakening!
- Harsin argues that
these exaggerated claims
made in the pursuit of profit
have fundamentally altered our worldviews.
He quotes theorist,
Alison Hearn, who writes,
"Promotionalism names the
extension of market values
and commodity relations
in all areas of life"
In a population so acclimatized
to the constant sell,
how can we recognize or
construct legitimate authority?
The link between the
language used in advertising
and the language used
to spread disinformation
becomes all the more apparent
when we look at the way Alex Jones
uses the same platforms to
propagate political rumors
and to sell dubious products,
like super male vitality supplements,
which I definitely didn't take
and which definitely didn't
give me a second penis
that knew all the words
to every kid rock song.
- That's how we fund this revolution
against the New World Order.
- In short, our culture
is saturated in (bleep)
and we're used to being lied to
by basically everyone at all times.
It's a fun way to live, right?
Feeling like we can't trust anything,
that everyone's lying to us.
You can trust me though, maybe.
As Harsin argues,
"American democracy has
been, among other things,
an evolving competition of fakery.
It could be said that
people would be irrational
not to be highly skeptical
of truth claims."
And skeptical they are.
Gallup polls have found that in 1997,
53% of respondents said they
trusted mass media reporting
to portray the news fully,
accurately, and fairly.
By 2021, just 29% of Americans
said they have a fair amount
of trust for the news.
And as journalists Tom Dow writes,
"When people cease to
trust the authorities,
they, some of them anyway,
become at once more skeptical
and more credulous."
And fake news is all too ready
to slide into the credulous folks' DMs.
Thus, it's never been
easier to fall for something
that isn't true.
And this played out especially painfully
during the 2016 presidential election.
A story about the Pope
endorsing Trump, for instance,
ricochet across Facebook
with nearly a million engagements
to bring it before voters' eyes.
And disappointed voters
found their own solace
in a story that got
nearly as many engagements
post-election,
that Ireland would take
in American refugees
which you know isn't true,
because I'm not broadcasting
live from Galway Bay.
It's why up to 40% of Americans
don't believe the results of
the last presidential election.
And it's why a Pew Research poll
in the summer of 2020
found that, largely thinks
to traction gained on Twitter
and elsewhere online,
71% of Americans had heard
the conspiracy theory
that COVID was planned by governments
possibly in hopes of injecting
citizens with microchips
to be tracked on 5G networks,
And a third of those
people believed the theory.
If you're looking for an online community
where people won't convince you
that you have 5G in your body
you should jump on "Wisecrack's" Discord,
which is a perk you get
by joining our Patreon,
where not only do you
get our Discord server,
you get the videos early and without ads,
you have access to extra
philosophy office hours with me,
extra podcast content.
Check it out.
We got a lot of stuff going on
and I promise we will not try
to conspiracy theory you much.
So where does all of this leave us?
As Stanford scholar
Renee DiResta explains,
"We are living in an
epistemological take-down
wherein people think facts
don't exist anymore."
And that feels like a pretty
daunting problem to have.
But this isn't the first
time humans have grappled
with concerns about the
extinction of truth.
A key question asked by
some of the philosophers
associated with postmodernism
was whether or not truth
was still a useful category.
Now, this is in contrast
to ancient philosophers,
like Plato and Aristotle,
and some more modern
idealists, like Kant Hegle,
who in their own ways
all believed that human reason
could arrive at some understanding
of universal truths and concepts.
But for philosophers like Jacque Derrida
and Emmanuel Levinas,
who drew inspiration from
19th century thinkers
like Nietzche and Kierkegaard,
classically metaphysical models of truth
sort of flatten the realities
of actual human existence
and often favor a more theological
or hierarchical way of thinking.
Now, according to philosopher
Jean-Francois Lyotard,
post-modernism is defined
by an incredulity towards metanarratives.
Now, in other words,
post-modernism is a sensibility
which is skeptical of metaphysical
or scientific modes of thinking
which claim to explain everything
in one consistent system,
i.e., that all existence
is oriented towards one cosmic
omnipotent being or concept.
Now, Derrida thought
that instead of some
universal hierarchical truth,
meaning has more to do with close readings
that reckon with a fundamental
difference or undecidability
in all texts and situations.
For some, this seems like an admittance
that truth doesn't exist
and everything is ultimately subjective,
while for others this is a
position of epistemic humility.
Now for Derrida, this meant
that the notions of truth
that underlie various
colonial political projects
were no longer to be taken
as universally valid,
which too many would be very, very good.
But for others,
making truth supposedly subjective
could have the cultural effect
of creating a free-for-all
in which all ideas of truth
and justice are equally valid.
And philosophers like Alain Badiou
have noted how this free
market approach to truth
has been a wonderful gift for capitalism
as it takes traditional
categories of truth,
like art, love, science,
and turns them into things
that can be more easily
marketed, bought, or sold.
So art becomes culture.
Love becomes sex.
Science becomes technology.
For example scientific
innovation and discovery
used to be motivated
by a desire to better understand
ourselves and the cosmos.
But technology became about using science
to build fancy gizmos that
makes stockholders happy.
And while love was once about
authentic romantic connection,
now dating apps and websites call our data
while teaching us to reduce the complexity
of love and sexuality
to a few doctored images on our phones.
In mine, I have lots of hair.
Things that once gave meaning to our lives
now become mere products.
For Badiou, the reintroduction of truth
is necessary to combat this.
But rather than the singular
truth of Plato or religion,
he argues for truths
which are relative to specific situations.
And these truths are what
can give meaning to our lives
outside of the free market,
whether that truth is a
lover, a commitment to art,
a passion for science,
or a desire for justice.
And in case you're thinking,
"Yeah, but what if my truth is fascism?"
Badiou argues that the thing
that all truths have in common
is a principle of equality.
So I guess your fascist streams
will have to remain just that.
But in the absence of
such high-minded ideals,
we're left in the ruthless ruins
that post-modern capitalism has rot
and that makes it really easy
for misinformation to
infiltrate the discourse,
which is one thing
if you decide to become
a quirky flat Earther,
but another when you start pizzagating
with a side of doxing.
But what do you all think?
Is our society too fractured
to agree upon anything ever again
or can we regain even
a modicum of reverence
for truth and objectivity
to save ourselves?
Let us know in the comments.
And if you haven't checked it out yet,
please come hang out with
us at our new stream,
"Wisecrack Live."
It happens right here every
Thursday at 11:00 AM Pacific.
Thanks to our patrons as always,
and please, please like this video
if you found that it gave
you real information.
As always, thanks for watching.
I'll catch you later.
(upbeat music)